em qual o lugar do negro na sua cidade
você já parou para pensar sobre isso
se você saberia responder eu estou
falando de lugar ou localização no
espaço mas também de lugar social é um
lugar de destaque está no mesmo patamar
dos demais grupos ou ele simplesmente
não faz parte das narrativas sobre a
cidade na mesma época em que essa
questão foi colocada um dia enquanto eu
dava aula quando eu falei a palavra
escravidão um aluno negro cruzou os
braços
o e baixou a cabeça aquilo me marcou
ou será que a gente não tem mais nada
para falar sobre o negro na cidade a não
ser isso escravidão
e a gente
é mas
e se for para falar do negro como
escravo quer dizer escravo não escravisa
nem que seja para dizer que essa cidade
dependia do trabalho desses homens e
dessas mulheres para as mais diversas
funções
e ele zero pedreiros pintores alfaiates
babás quitandeiras a as negras minas e
também horas
e essas mulheres exímia quituteira só
que com seus tabuleiros de doce são seus
caldeirões de canjica o mocotó eram as
responsáveis pelo comércio de alimento
na cidade segundo aquiles porto alegre
como não haviam naquela época roças de
verdura as meninas é que andam de casa
em casa fornecendo a freguesia
as outras no entanto não perambular
exponham seus quitutes no mercado ou nas
cavernas destino
bom e se for para falar do nego no
período da escravidão que seja para
dizer que 1814 praticamente metade da
população da cidade de porto alegre era
negra que esses homens essas mulheres
pagaram pela maior parte das suas
ocorrências contra o dinheiro fruto do
seu trabalho economizado os são curtos
tão libertar assim seus filhos seus com
jesus sim e-mail escravidão as pessoas
negras também informava o famílias
e com direito a batismo na igreja do
rosário a igreja dos pretos
bom então se for a irmandade do rosário
é emblema 1
e por isso se for para falar e seja para
lembrar das estratégias negras
o imagine e cem anos antes da abolição
da escravidão quando a cidade não
passava de algumas poucas ruas um grupo
de 200 pessoas negras entre livres
escravizados davam o mesmo significado
irmandades do rosário irmandade é essa
inclusive vai construir a sua própria
igreja para poder ter mais liberdade nas
suas ações como a realização dos campos
e os que clubes também conhecidos como
congada sou umas ambix era uma mistura
entre o ar tejo e procissão com
elementos de matriz africana como música
dança e percussão seu fecho os olhos
se eu consigo ver a congada do
maçambique de osório levando à frente a
rainha ginga e o rei com seguidos pelos
dançantes e com os seus nos pés vão
cantando e dançando no caminho até a
igreja o tambor tá batendo na
repinicando é uma sambique senhor o teu
amor tá chamando é tambor chama
e me digam
o fe o estímulo à formação de poupança o
estímulo à educação a realização de
cultos não eram importantes estratégias
de fortalecimento e ascensão coletiva
tá bom mas e se for para falar do negro
no espaço urbano que seja para lembrar
da rua dos pretos
os forros estava relacionado ao correr
porque a gente também pode alarme de
verdade
a ser fogo era ter conquistado alforria
cercou era ser livre rua dos
pretos-forros a gente já pode imaginar
que reside a era ali que residia o
redator do jornal negro o exemplo
existentes por quase quatro décadas a
até o jornal negro de porto alegre saber
não só porto alegre como diversas outras
cidades do rio grande do sul
e a rua dos pretos-forros era também o
limite de um importante território né o
areal da baronesa aliás é significativo
que os dois limites deste antigo
território negro fossem datas da
emancipação mesmo a rua treze de maio
data da abolição da escravidão ea rua
dos pretos-forros que depois passa a se
chamar rua vinte e oito de setembro data
da lei do ventre livre
é a lei do ventre livre foi muito
importante para a população nele porque
ela determinou que todo filho nascido de
mulher escrava seria livre
o isac estamos falando em nomes da
liberdade vamos falar da redenção
principal parque urbano cartão postal e
pontos turístico você sabe por quê que o
parque da redenção se chama redenção
é o nome redenção foi dado para
comemorar a libertação a redenção dos
escravisados o
e hoje o parque da redenção não é mais
lembrado como um lugar de presença nele
embora no passado fosse lembrado pelos
batuques ao seu redor assim se for para
nos homenagear que seja
só para lembrar dos batuques na redenção
meditando o famoso candombe da mãe rita
essa mulher negra tinta automotiva em 11
ah mas você não sabe aonde fica eu te
entendo eu também não sabia e foi por
isso que os marquei nos mapas para que a
gente pudesse saber mas esse não era o
único batuque ao redor da redenção
tinham também os fatos em frente à
capelinha do bonfim ali na avenida
osvaldo aranha no caminho da colônia
africana
e a colônia africana era um dos antigos
territórios negros da cidade junto com a
bacia do monserrat o areal da baronesa e
aí ó tá o que são chamando de
territórios negros eram grandes áreas
mais habitadas em sua maioria por
famílias negras esses números ficaram
lembrados pelos carnavais pelas casas de
bato pelos salões de bye pelos times de
futebol com a liga da canela preta ou a
rua do monte serrat que tinha 7 casas de
batom a mesma rua
e hoje o bairro monserrat é um dos vai é
um dos metros quadrados mais caros da
cidade não sendo lembrado como um antigo
território nela na sua cidade
se você já tinha ouvido falar
territórios negros na sua cidade existem
lugares que remetem
e a essa presença negra como esses
lugares são lembranças
é mas não esqueço se for para lembrar
que seja para lembrar da luta dos
quilombos que hoje se localizam em áreas
nobres da cidade como quilombo do silva
primeiro quilombo urbano reconhecido do
brasil ou quilombo dos alpes que se
localiza numa área ou paisagem e vista
valorizada quando essas comunidades
chegaram essas áreas não eram
valorizados na maior parte das vezes
ficavam inclusive distantes da parte
urbanizada da cidade hoje com a
valorização imobiliárias espaços essas
comunidades passam a pedro o seu direito
ao pergunta ao território questionar a
é a maior parte desses antigos
territórios negros não existe mais a
cidade se transformou as grandes
reformas urbanas tanto queriam
modernizá-la também acabaram colocando
abaixo uma boa parte do nosso passado
muitas memórias foram soterrados
os seus antigos moradores deslocados
empurrados para áreas de estamos
é mas é preciso lembrar porque isso
esses antigos espaços fazem parte da
nossa memória
e da nossa memória coletiva e pontos
cidade na nossa história de cidade e na
sua cidade qual o lugar do negro
bom obrigado